rouyn-noranda talent plus ni moins
elle n'a gardé que son prénom de la
roumanie
cf da 24 ans chante sa passion sous le
regard bienveillant de sa mère je suis à
l'université de montréal
je commence ma troisième année de bac en
chant classique
j'ai dû travailler très fort pour
réussir donc avec le déficit d'attention
sa demande est beaucoup plus de plus de
travail adoptée à l'âge de trois ans et
demi par jeanine keane elle est arrivée
au québec en 1998 il avait l'air d'un
enfant de deux ans et demi à
l'orphelinat elle allait tout les
bassines et puis il y avait une petite
table où ils s'étaient tous attablés
pour manger je me suis avec elle à la
table d'à côté
et puis la belle a commencé à m'offrir
de faire de sa nourriture
depuis ce moment elles ne se sont plus
quittés je n'étais pas facile pour une
femme seule d'adopter il fallait être en
couple
qu'est ce qui est dur avec l'adoption
c'est que non seulement on se fait oui
arraché de notre naissance on se fait
arracher notre langue qui on était puis
pendant longtemps je ne m'aime même
encore de la colère liée à ça plairait
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
avaient beaucoup d'insécurité c'est très
nerveux et il était toujours là pour moi
c'est la m
elle a toujours voulu apprendre et
persévérante aussi je serai fière d'elle
je veux dire je sais d'où elle est
partie
il m'a bien commun comme un petit garçon
cette date serait la septième enfant de
sa famille biologique
à l'époque le dictateur nicolae
ceausescu mener une politique de
natalité sans merci
il exigeait cinq enfants minimum par
famille faute de pouvoir les nourrir les
familles abandonner leurs enfants en
1990 le monde entier découvre la
tragédie des orphelinats roumains des
centaines d'orphelinats bond est dans un
état calamiteux parfois sans eau ni
chauffage
michel lavoie a gardé les coupures de
presse de cette époque il est père de
deux garçons adopté en roumanie dix
mille romain décédé lurmen de se dire un
avortement illégal
la part des femmes devait aussi mettre
sur leur lieu de travail à un test de
grossesse mensuel citait cette épouse
cfld vert est obligé de mettre au monde
neuf rock star dans son ambition la plus
folle le dictateur voulait que les plus
résistants des orphelins me servent plus
tard de garde rapprochée j'étais enfermé
dans des grandes salles dans des
bassines est un peu comme des du bétail
si on veut aucune stimulation ça
causerait un déficient sommes dubois
festif aussi cette soif d'attention
jamais complètement assouvi sera le lot
de beaucoup de parents adoptants qui
essaie de combler ce manque que leurs
enfants dès la naissance dans mon encore
ben ça causait europe ce c'était le
catalyseur son voeu 7 trade selon niveau
de la dynamique de famille s'est
accaparé à tout moment mais je ne
regrette rien il expose fièrement les
photos de ses fils qui vivent avec une
déficience légère et un besoin continu
d'encadrement tentes à plus tard j'ai
deux beaux garçons sont des adultes
n'est fait
les deux enfants que des grandes forces
au niveau mémoire il a pris jusqu'à sept
à huit langues maintenant qui peut
parler et puis il apprend la musique
peut jouer du piano il peut composer
par contre c'est une honte at on ciblait
de l'info c'est à quelle date quel mois
pour lui hier où il ya cinq ans c'est la
même chose
georges et c'est le pianiste chez les
richards adopté à l'âge de 4 ans il a
aussi une déficience légère
à 31 ans il est la prunelle des yeux de
sa mère le piano il ya commencé à 8 ans
mais c'est ce qu'il fallait que je sois
derrière puis que je l'aï dépit que des
fois il y avait dans le coin aujourd'hui
il travaille à temps plein jutras
travailleurs le dans une entreprise
adaptée chez stan donc morrow - séjourna
lien donc je des palettes de bourgeois
décalés son bourg
georges et revient de loin faute de
personnel dans son orphelinat il était
souvent attachés comme beaucoup d'autres
enfants quand j' en ai georges il
pouvait pas marcher un dry fallait
qu'ils marchaient peu fallait toujours
qu'un dry le transporte une fois
montréal comme beaucoup le couple son
tour de professionnels de la santé
j'ai eu des traumatismes c'est sûr on
sait pas de quel ordre il fait son école
primaire à la maison avec sa mère le
couple suit alors les conseils d'un
neurologue
ils vont se créer des nouveaux circuits
si on le stimule et c'est ce qu'ils ont
fait ils haïssent en est bien sûr ticks
on est fier de ce georges et réclame
alors une soeur lise adoptent nicoletta
quelques années plus tard de roumanie de
collecte et c'est les bonbons et le
vannes oc
à 26 ans elle poursuit ses études en
psychologie et travaille dans un centre
de réinsertion
c'est un sens dans l'insertion sociale
qui vient aider à tous ceux qui ont des
problématiques indépendance soit à la
toque secours l'alcoolisme ou à toute
autre personne de minutes
on fait la réinsertion pour le sahara
que je cherche c'est vraiment le
sentiment de devoir aider quelqu'un à sa
joie même si c'est juste les couteaux
ont la partie peut-être de rien à une
belle famille qu'on s'est construit au
fil du temps j'ai eu droit à moins d'une
meilleure condition de vie sains et la
salle a pu j'ai pu lui main miment
anticipé dans tout mon développement
personnel mais mon cheminement est donc
maintenant je suis fier de m'apercevoir
qu'embêtant ben j'ai pu aussi m'acheter
une maison avec ma conjointe donc ça
c'est une autre affaire ok je pensais
pas réaliser et qui s'est muré un rail
qui passait à la réalité les efforts que
mes parents ont fait auprès de moi et
que donc je n'oublierai jamais notre
première idée c'était il faut que joris
est plus besoin de nous et puis on est
arrivé là
soldat espère visiter un jour la
roumanie avec sa mère nicoletta aussi
georges et lui n'est pas intéressé
chacun semble avoir trouvé sa voie au
canada
[Musique]